(Music)
Emily has a wild imagination.
Bee, I was hoping you'd come.
What's up?
(Music)
Alena Smith:
She's always asking for someone
to understand her.
And it feels like she becomes
increasing alone.
Alena Smith:
But because she's Emily, she's
conducting all sorts of
Alena Smith:
relationships with imaginary
figures.
How did you get inside?
Girl, I flew through the window.
Hailee Steinfeld:
The Bee is a figment of Emily's
imagination.
The Bee shows up every time
Emily was feeling a bit lost, or
alone.
Will you dance with me?
Hailee Steinfeld:
And the bumblebee will sort of
come in and save the day.
Bee, you're so sweet.
I'm covered in pollen, baby.
Emily:
Bee!
Alena Smith:
The show explores that being
alone,
Alena Smith:
can be tough, but perhaps that
was the very thing
that generated such
powerful creativity.
May I have this dance?
Bee, you don't mind, do you?
(Music)
Buzz...